good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the first press conference of
president from the line dedicated to the
readout of the first meeting of the
College of Commissioners President the
floor is yours thank you very much and a
very warm welcome from my side too
yes I want to report from the very first
college meeting which was for the very
first time a paperless College meeting
it was completely digital so it's a
first important step towards a digital
organization I know that as a whole we
have still a very very much to do but
having a paperless college is an
important first step I want to report on
what we've decided on today in the
college the working methods and then we
had reports on cop 25 in Madrid the hrbp
reported briefly from NATO the
Commission Elena church about Albania
was going to travel to today to be there
tomorrow and vice president Yoruba and
Commissioner winders reported from Malta
so first of all let's have a look at the
working methods we have been deciding on
today the Commission sees itself as one
team yes we do come from very different
backgrounds and different countries we
have different political colors but we
work as one College for one union and
this is our European Union we have all
our say in the college we decide
together and it is important that when
we have taken a decision we also thereby
take ownership all of us
this subject as it has been decided in
the college I emphasize this because we
always say that Europe is strong when it
is united and when it acts as one so if
the unity has to start here at the core
of the European institutions in the
college we have organized the work of
the Commission in such that if you look
at my six priorities and the guidelines
they are of course all interconnected
for example climate and digital have a
strong interconnection for an economic
growth strategy but we organized it as
such that an executive vice president or
a vice president is responsible for a
cluster with different commissioners we
call them commissioners group and they
are shared by the respective
vice-president or executive
vice-president or HR VP these
commissioners groups will ensure
coordination and coherence across the
Commission but the decisions of course
are being taken in the college we have
been taken a decision on the
geopolitical commission of course the
HIV people will support me in
coordinating the external dimension of
all commissioners work our external
action will be systematically discussed
and decided on by the college that was a
reason for example that today we had the
NATO report we will have every Wednesday
in college now a report on external
action and we have created a new
preparatory body the so-called xqo
external coordination that brings
together the cabinet's of all
commissioners to bridge mainly the
action that is external and internal
because both have a strong influence on
the Commission's work a few more topics
on the composition of our cabinet as you
know I've asked to include at least 50
sent women in all our cabinets at
administrative level we've reached that
goal for the very first time this is a
little revolution I'm proud of that at
the same time it should be normal it
should not be an issue and we've asked
to bring as many nationalities as
possible to the respective cabinets I'm
proud to say that we have in my cabinet
16 different nationalities and I've
encouraged my colleagues to raise the
numbers of nationalities in their teams
- last but not least an information on
the think-tank on the current European
political strategy center we will build
a new structure it is structured by the
six headlines of the political
guidelines or represented by the VP's I
want to keep the Femmes function of an
internal think tank at the same time I
want to adapt it to a new geopolitical
reality and to our new priorities we'll
call it ideal the acronym as always it's
an acronym for inspired debate engage
and accelerate action just a short
report on the cup 25 in Madrid first of
all I want to commend Spain for an
outstanding work and putting up with in
three weeks this huge conference this
was impressive I think it was very good
that I was there on my very first
working day on Monday to contribute to
making the European Green Deal a
reference for climate action I announced
that we will adopt the European Green
Deal
in the communication kind of a roadmap
next week on December 11th and presented
a few short ideas
within the three minutes we all did have
for our contributions the first one is
that I'm convinced only what gets
measured gets done and therefore we
announced at the cup 25 that in 2020 we
will have the first ever climate law in
place so that our road towards climate
neutrality in 2050 will be irreversible
the second point is investment
investment will be crucial to be
successful with the European Green Deal
for that we will present the sustainable
Europe and vestment plan to mobilize
investment and as you know the just
transition fund to leave no one behind
we make very clear that we want to be
ambitious in the negotiations and the
cop 25 I think the European Green Deal
could be seen as a real contribution to
something like a global Green Deal it
was good to see that all the European
leaders President Susilo was there and
president Michele was there too more or
less increasingly aligning on the
European Green Deal so it's going in the
right direction what our continent is
concerned but of course the cup 25 is a
vast international one impressive is
that we have the shared view that Europe
can be and must be a front-runner in
this topic but obviously they are also
concerned how we gonna finance that
mainly the transition and it is true
that we do not all start from the same
point and that is why we put forward the
just transition fund I want to inform
you that we are working towards an
aspirational target of mobilizing under
the Justin
mechanism together with the eiv group
100 billion euros of investments during
the period of the next mff in order to
reach that target we're building a
mechanism that draws and sources of
funding from the EU budget from the
European Union but also co-founded by
the Member States as well as the EIB
group to leverage the necessary public
and private means at the same time and I
think this is important too when we're
talking about costs of the European
Green Deal at the same time we should
always keep in mind what the cost of
non-action would be and there are costs
already so I asked the Commissioner
septa coverage of foresight to present
us next week the known costs already for
the European Union of climate change so
that we have an idea what the costs of
non-action would be in the future and
that we know all aligned in the being
convinced that acting on the Green Deal
is a good investment than the right
investment for a better future in a
healthy planet I'm convinced that this
is yes the European Green Deal fighting
climate change change it is not only
necessary is it it is a huge opportunity
for the European Union we are at the
moment being the front-runner if we do
it right if we invest in research and
innovation in green technologies
sustainable solutions and new businesses
we will be able to demonstrate as a
trendsetter
that this can be for the European Union
a new growth strategy and at the same
time if we make the transition we're
able to give people confidence we are
able to give the economy confidence
and hope that this is moving in the
right direction change of topic
Albania the European Union and I had a
phone call with Prime Minister Atacama
on Sunday stands in full solidarity with
Albania with actions not only with words
we support already on the ground we are
committed to providing more so far the
Commission has helped to mobilize three
search-and-rescue teams of more than 200
staff from Italy Greece and Romania
we've dispatched tens beds blankets
sleeping bags generators and hygiene
items for emergency needs by a Belgium
Romania Austria and Slovakia
Commissioner lenarcik will travel today
to Albania he is there mainly to provide
a cute assessment for the state the
buildings are in that are affected and
of course to have an primary assessment
on what kind of help is needed for
reconstruction as a very first step we
will allocate from the neighborhood fund
15 million immediately to support the
Albanian people and we've decided in
college that we will organize a donors
conference I will call today at Irama
again to inform him about these effects
last topic in the college meeting was
Malta I am concerned by the recent
developments in Malta and we are
following the situation very closely to
be very clear on that we harshly condemn
the murder of the journalist Daphne her
murder was an attack on free media
Media freedom is the foundation of our
free and democratic society journalists
must feel safe to work in Europe if not
democracy as we know it will be under
threat I will not comment on ongoing
national investigations however what I
will say is that I expect there to be a
thorough and independent investigation
free from any political interference
Europol is in Malta it is providing
support to the Maltese authorities it is
crucial that all those responsible are
brought to justice as soon as possible
the Commission is also in contact with
the Maltese authorities on the reform of
the judicial system and we will continue
to work with the authorities to
accelerate these reforms this is it for
the moment what
thank you mrs. president now the
president will now take your questions
and focusing first on the issues
discussed in the college as she
presented them yes